breeding some podcast Vil the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by hymns listen with age comes wisdom
but getting older can also be a downer
in one specific area 40% of men by the
age of 40 struggle from not being able
to get and maintain an erection I'm not
talking about nobody specifically but
you know who the hell you are
why do guys turn to weird solutions that
do nothing when they could turn to
medicine and science expensive pills
injections when no one wants an
injection you don't need no that stuff
that's wrong for Joey comes in for hims
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care and sexual wellness for men listen
even if you don't need it you might as
well get one of these just so you give a
double the handle or you know I'm saying
everybody wants to be remembered that's
what you need right there
after you make love you won't have to
even send a postcard so remember you
hymns works real easy prescription
solutions backed by science and they're
made more affordable so do me a favor
try them for a month for five hours
you like joy what the hell are you
talking about five hours will get you
started for just five bucks while
supplies last prescription products the
subjects that doctors approval and
require an online consultation with the
physician who will determine if the
prescription is appropriate see the
website for full details and safety
information all right this could cost
you hundreds of dollars if you went to a
doctor in person and you'll be
embarrassed
nanananana just go to for hems comm
slash Church CH you are CH that's for
hems dot-com slash church the church is
also brought to you by you ready for
this so now you got your helmet and
tip-top walk correct now I got you some
hems and you got the helmet maybe I'll
be a gentleman everybody wants to get
that pole sucked but it looks like a
[__] it looks like the Amazon jungle
down there half of it is burning your
balls got mold on it I'm
here to tell you uncle Joey's gonna
[__] help you out the fall is coming
put away the white [__] clothes all
right it's time to [__] trim your
[__] nut sack and the [__] trees a
little lawn around the tree my friends
over at manscaped created the one and
only tool that you need to shave your
balls and the area around your [__]
pole of love it's called a man lo the
lawnmower 2.0 for a reason
they threw away 21.0 and they upgraded
that trimmer with the skin-safe
technology now the church listeners can
get 20% off your first order when you
use promo code church at manscape calm
and if you order the perfect package to
also throw in a free travel bag when you
use the code church that CH you are CH
that's manscape com use promo code
church for 20% off your first order and
keep your [__] nut sack
smelling tip-top [__] Magoo all right
Lee
check this [__] meal what's up
DC good to see man thanks for might have
this ban should've showed up at the VMAs
and just blew the comic everybody's
torturing the [__] Victor the
attendant nobody want little nobody
wants watch that [__] no Chris Cornell
his voices oh one of a kind Chris
Cornell Howard up with a mountain garden
at the VMAs on Sunday for Miley Cyrus
she was the only good act Miley Cyrus
was the only one that brought everybody
else is up there jumping up and down
those Chinese kids a blind man never
seen those [__] little communist
before what they company they're Korean
whatever the [__] they are those are the
12 kids that were stuck in the cage they
gave five of them in a wrecking
contracting [__] kids I guarantee when
they come from I don't even know these
little Chinese kids were jumping up and
down oh yeah what the [__] do these been
how okay pop yeah how old am i I don't
know no nobody I new Miley Cyrus the
other skinny [__] I don't like her at
all who the skinny I didn't watch I
didn't wanna be a [__] the one they
she's trying to get a music back
I feel bad thrown out is Taylor Taylor
Swift oh she's a skinny ho no less but
I'm just saying she's a [__] [__]
with that skinny little [__] write a
song and she looks like she can't she
looks like she could suck a good dick
Kayla's gotta look like she'll mop that
dick up after you manscape your helmet
so suck that [__] but she's got
like a little tiny [__] like Kate
Quigley like you like he's got a great
ass but he [__] looks like she needs to
grow a bush to fill it in like like a
bumper it goes down I don't like [__]
they go down that means you got no meat
there you gotta have some [__] meat
that I can bite into like like jaws like
a healthy labia yeah yeah yeah I didn't
watch the VMA but I'm the same way like
I said because of Sebastian right right
I was alright I was on a flight for the
pork yeah and he was hurray I mean
listen when somebody calls you up all I
read about the last two days his
criticism of Dave Chappelle and the
criticism of Sebastian how bad the VMAs
but listen the VMAs a bad every [__]
yet right I mean it's just kids whatever
the [__] they are but Sebastian was
great friends the comic you have no idea
what it's like yeah yeah and handcuffs
that are put on you a shin you have no
idea so before you open your mouth about
Sebastian [__] jump through a glass
window see what it feels like and then
get back you know I I didn't I didn't
hear about like the Chappelle thing but
I did read you saturday was out I feel
bad worse with names and never met him
personally but the satyr Night Live
young Pete oh my god
not even it David yep yes yes Davidson
he there was some article about him I
was reading this yesterday and I was
outraged about the writer of the article
and also the campus beating a college
show and he just called them entitled
[__] and went on a rant and and then
the college like went off on him about
how unprofessional and how terror
any comic who's done college gigs it's
like night but no they were [__]
entitled [__] probably on their
phone being pieces of shits and then it
just said that the college can't like
you know take responsibility for their
own students being [__] and just go
the easy route of just being like oh my
god he ruined everybody's night by by
saying some horrible things about our
beloved students but yet people just
like to pick on comics I mean like
nicest guy in comedy made a statement 18
months ago he's the nicest cleanest
comic of all time Jerry sighs oh yeah
and this guy made a public statement
that said you could not pay him enough
to do a college yeah yeah and you have
to think about that now I know a lot of
college kids come to my shows right I
have no problems when you come to my
show but I know if I went to the
University of Notre Dame and my act
thrown at me because it's the wrong kids
coming to those shows that there's
awesome kids at those campuses campuses
but the ones who aren't [__] partying
on a Friday nights who want to come to
the whether or not selling alcohol not
that you have to have been oh I mean
like who could that type of student they
tend to be more outraged in my opinion
so I use do tons of colleges and I'm
like oh this I know that there's people
here who would love what's happening but
not these [__] you know that they
came tonight and then the administrators
are the ones to get me I did one the
last one I only did one in the last two
years but I told him I'm like I get to
say whatever I want no censorship at all
and they let me do that and it was a
blast who'd they take the ride the kids
they did they did because I went hard at
the beginning extra hard just to let him
know just to let him know right there
was some of the picture of their their
founder of their college I just [__]
read about what a creepy ass looking
lady she would look like and some
bucking torturing kids and her [__]
basement on some neato Island but like
but she looked [__] creepy and then
they were like shocked at first and then
they loosened up and then we had a great
time and because I had that freedom but
like you're talking with the handcuffs
you know like Sebastian's like love
these people understand they're told you
can't say this you can't do that am I
doing this and it's like they just take
all of your arsenal away from you and
then want you to go to battle as I got
no weapon was great yeah whether he's my
friend than I thought he was great
listen I watch
those shows because he we're all
together well connected yeah and when
one of us rises we all brings County up
we all rise up you know it's like an
anything this is how you have to look at
it yeah if you want to succeed in any
field you have to be happy
sincerely happy for the people around
you the people you came up with right
you hold any type of anger or issues
you're just not gonna grow yeah just
know I don't ever talk about this all
day this is like team do you know why
because for a while when you get here
and things aren't happening right you
fall into that why ain't happening for
Dan I got what spots here I'm funnier
here and right at the end you're
supposed to be all hand in hand yeah and
it really isn't like that I wish that
all comedians hold each other hand and
hands around the world yeah it would
never happen because but that's why the
world is the world but as long as we
have a little circle yeah like I have my
little circle yeah we'll hold hands to
the debt that's the way it is as I have
we started you know me and Josh wolf we
know each other from day one I got yeah
yeah no choice but to have his back yeah
you know Brody it was a huge kick in my
stomach especially for me because I
known for 20 years I should write like
an autumn more what the [__] was wrong
with me you know we're a family
sebat you know when will I sit there and
the first thing I read on Twitter on a
Monday morning or a Tuesday morning from
Vice land is how bad [__] Chappelle's
Show is I think of myself
vice land first off I love what you're
trying to do but have you watched your
[__] show lately that show about
eating weed with those three little half
a [__] you got is the worst [__] show
I've ever seen in my goddamn life you
know I didn't episode Danny Brown it was
growling Danny Brown show yeah we've had
some great drug shows but [__] 50
percent of your [__] is totally [__]
garbage so for you to put down Chappelle
before you put down Chappelle go clean
up your own [__] backyard
especially with that [__] we'd show
you got that we culture with those three
little half of [__] that never smoked
the bonding in their life you get me
I'll get some three hard-hit [__] just
like [__] you said in pub friction
what a thing ring say I'll get some
hard-hitting [__] and we'll do that
we've [__] showing y'all show you what
a weak culture is they did Cuban food
I wouldn't even eat that Cuban food
nevermind I wouldn't eat that Cuban food
if you had gold in it
this [__] they made that did the [__]
terrible that we'd coach the show it's
the worst show I've ever seen in my
[__] life are you angry Dave didn't
do it that's the only reason like well
what are they were they should not I
didn't hear this or just said then what
did they do like what show his his tan
his new standard bad new he did a new
special call sticks and stones what is
that out already
oh [__] lady am I going you know what
man I think that it came out too quickly
yeah maybe Dave didn't prepare his
material oh my God we're wrong our
turkey burgers it yeah I just I thought
that I thought athlete jealousy had the
specialty here until I watched Dave
Chappelle Wow Mike Anthony I love you to
death but holy [__]
Dave Chappelle special was fired when I
watched the first 45 minutes that's a
lot from go Joey right I took the first
piece smoke break at 45 minutes that's
[__] good that's pretty odd years
since I've sat and watch the special
after 25 minutes yeah I gotta see the ex
I stopped me I saw the previous three
but that's great well now I know what I
gotta watch it so weed that we live in
this what do you recorded Atlanta and he
says a bit in there about I'm gonna do
an impersonation you know in 25 years
you're gonna do any cuz I'm talking
about you guys and he just pointed to
all the little niches we have in a
society now you know about how people
come back and attack yeah for 20 years
oh right right right like what Jax has
been dead for ten years there's got to
court cases how the [__] does this
happen you know and they should hear
damn I'm sitting in like two more
accusers have come up in the case the
the the there's a chiropractor at the
University of Michigan or something oh
yeah for 10 years and now you want to
come out
go go go waste your time go to church go
hang out with some of those pedophile
priests kids and go talk about your
issues leave these [__] beat the guys
been dead for [__] 20 years now you
want to come out and say why he was
touching your footing fingered you go
[__] yourself this is why you can't even
give those people light yeah how do
those people to go away like what kills
me is when it's not even something that
made you that happened 20 like when
somebody tweeted lyrics of a song that
had like racist language and they're an
athlete now and then now they come back
and be like and then the person goes and
cries does an apology I wish more people
would just be like no [__] oh yeah I was
[__] 15 I was my song you know the
song I liked or whatever or said some or
whatever I was 15 I said some dumb [__]
like all 15 year-olds do
go [__] yourself like well it makes me
upset when they when they actually do
the press conference apologies I wish
more people would say no I'm not gonna
apologize for what I said I don't owe
you that that's why I don't owe you an
apology from 500 lost years ago that's
what [__] lost the chick who pulled
the head up for Trump
Oh was she apologized that's when she
lost Cathy oh yes yes that's right
that's right you never apologized right
yeah thought it was funny you don't like
it throw the album's away if I go on TV
and burn those outside a you cuz I'm
gonna sell a million more yeah the quiet
right then they do it to one of those
bands they took their albums in this oh
yeah yes Mac yeah yeah yeah no the black
dudes
oh no and waw a 2 Live Crew and w8o that
was one big Sycamore tipper gore well
all that kind of when they said the
IceCube look at them they're burning our
albums and he goes I don't care they pay
for you know I mean I today one article
came out from variety that said it
didn't really meant that it's a song
about some bash oh the whole thing was
so bad I used to love you Sebastian but
but the the save space until you came on
a safe space and the thing the thing
that upset me and I stopped reading the
article well she was like I used to love
watching the VMAs and I'm a fan of you
but people get triggered and then she
spent what she spent like least favorite
words she spent like three or four
paragraphs
think about her Organization for safe
spaces and like oh you're just trying to
get you have nothing against Sebastian
you just want to get a little bit of
notoriety for your thing so they okay
I'm gonna stop reading this now but the
headline is Sebastian ruin the VMAs it's
not a safe space anymore that's why I
know I hope that's the fashions
management
they got a tremendous envelope firm
because if you get you get George Burns
and pull them out of the grave Abbott
and Costello private grave pull out all
the great comics out of a great having
right and how a fee and you do the
Oscars guess what you're still gonna get
some form of hatred yeah yeah yeah host
do you get me you're gonna get some form
of age oh yeah if you host whatever so
the formulas right you're gonna hate me
you got to pay me everything I want the
whole cash right yeah I want the door I
want over vodka [__] help you know I'm
saying people hate I mean I'm just going
off my list my writer is [__] twenty
pages because you're gonna you're gonna
get tormented that right it's just a
meaning meaningless torment like I look
at like on iTunes right like to do it
mad about trolls whatever there is not a
single album that has ever been made of
note that got you know a lot of exposure
that's only five stars you can look at
like the greatest you know the Stones
Exile on Main Street whatever you want
to find out there they're like this is a
[__] beautiful amazing album and
you're gonna find someone store booth
looking Koons really didn't appreciate
this what I mean people just want to
hate you're just gonna find and and I
would hope that Sebastian's looking at
like he just got seen by so many new
people that of course since they weren't
part of his fan base initially it's like
the more people who hate you that's it's
almost like the better because you're
just reaching so many new people before
and the ones who don't hate you
there's not gonna say they're not gonna
go online it's just the way human nature
is and talk about how much they love you
so I would hope therefore every person
that's given like backlash he hope that
he knows that there are thousands who
dislike that guy's [__] great they're
gonna come see him they're gonna buy his
stuff they're gonna come to his shows
yeah
YouTube kind of changed recently on the
contents I don't like when you actually
post stuff and then actually show it
used to show you how many likes and
dislikes you had yeah and like sometimes
like you look at this like junk car that
kind of so I don't but now what it does
is it actually shows you the percentage
of legs versus dislikes okay so good
it's ninety seven ninety five percent
like okay then I guess that's way better
yeah okay cannot understand one then
when you post though and I learned this
six or seven I stopped paying attention
to will anybody really said on the
internet years ago yeah well sometimes
I'll say something back to them to throw
them off right and sometimes you realize
people just say something nasty to you
so you could just tell them all you know
disappeared yeah told them others suck
my dick but I really learned a lot a
couple months ago what video in a
billion downloads it was a November rain
number they made a big deal about it
November rain first video ever on
YouTube to hit him Guns N'Roses
yeah I never write hit a billion a
billion Wow it was something and I went
on there was a billion yeah yeah yeah
number was and I went on there and they
still had a hundred and fifty thousand
eight right then go to the Beatles right
out yes and you'll see one of the
greatest albums ever put on vinyl and
watch the percentage of thumbs down yeah
and I sit there and I go I wonder who
would give the Beatles White Album the
from down I am you know yeah so you have
to stretch it along this whole process
of who has the time right when some yeah
right something who has an article I
really don't have the time right because
you're busy creating grueling day right
stuff yeah to think about all those
considerations before you let those
comments online yeah
affect you yeah I'm sure people in
Sebastian on either off you know I mean
you really cannot get in fact I never
read the comments I'm Rachel right I
knew that I felt in my heart
yep the job I did wasn't who I was so I
let it go on the plane ride home yeah
yeah yeah just didn't gold my favourite
this time you know saying I rolled the
six and I rolled the seven and that's
just the way life is sometimes I just
gotta like Sebastian at the end of his
monologue if you don't win this year
work harder next year right right right
well it's not like you just said
Chappelle had the best special of the
year he doesn't have a website he
doesn't have any social media no yeah so
it shows you what's really important hey
Stokes on the grass nothing
he has no Twitter no he doesn't do any
that self he says this mystique the
Chappelle mystique
how does he sell out 18 shows how do
people know she's [__] word-of-mouth
it's great he has no social media Hughes
used to call I mean four or five years
after the Chappelle show when it went
away Comedy Works in Denver and
punchline in San Francisco he would just
call him up like on a Monday night be
like hey I want to do
Tuesday and Wednesday to [__] you know
whatever show each night and they would
just send it out to their email list or
whatever on their stuff and they would
be sold out in minutes you know and it's
just like yeah he doesn't do any of that
nothing it's amazing no website nothing
no Dave Chappelle com
no no Leno there's nothing out there are
you [__] serious
yeah I didn't do any of that let me
double-check I mean if it's even if it's
out there it's brand-new cuz I checked
the past just cuz I was amazed to it I'm
like what no social media profile just
please come back later
it's amazing you know I stopped looking
I remember a couple years ago with
YouTube something went up it was this it
was uh you did that this is not
happening that story and they told me to
promote it when it went out so I just
wanted to make sure that it was because
I don't generally look at the YouTube
anyway as far as comments but I just
want to make sure that before I'm
tweeting or whatever posting that it's
actually there that I'm sending a link
to a real video and first comment that
was left some guy he said some of the
effect of Dan Cummins is the worst comic
of all time I hate every bit he's ever
done I hate it when I hear him on
Pandora and I hate but it's like and
will crack me up I start laughing cuz
I'm like let me get this straight I'm
the comic you [__] hate more than
anybody else on earth and the second a
new video of mine comes out you like
check this out it's like you're just an
idiot
you're an idiot like your opinion means
nothing yeah yeah and that's just that
troll nature they just wanted
today you know it's very very rare that
you see a feedback on there where you're
like it's constructive in any way you
know I think he's given a good effort
but really you know I think you know he
could have maybe just kind of shortened
this and maybe if he actually tried and
work on his timing it's just never like
[__] sucks
[__] piece of [__] just dumped just
dumb vapid hate it's crazy to me that
who would raise a child would be that
devious to go out of their way
yeah make up a different email going
quitter
like I always think about where their
life is that oh yeah
like okay if Dan communist wants to say
Joey I saw your last special I wasn't
happy with it
I could go Dan guess what neither was I
you know but when I go back to your
website and there's and all your Twitter
or you yeah there's no picture there's a
picture of like a Russian girl that you
could tell it's not you right and you
know it's a fake website right they
don't have the balls to put themselves
out there I think about that I think
about what their life is like yep I
think about all it's like my was a
[__] junkie and a thief all the time
I put in to scam if I were to pull into
something positive
right I could have done something
positive you doing something that's
halfway positive yeah yeah you're
actually getting you're figuring some
right up but you're figuring it out for
the wrong way like for the wrong thing
if you figured this much out and you use
this in a positive way the answer that
you're looking for yeah would ya be
happy oh my god I'm saying I won't say
his name I won't say his name but he's
describing the person we've had a
problem with like like there's like you
say like what is going on in this
person's life
I know a person that I worked with him
years ago and all the way it didn't work
out we worked on a few projects together
and not even like a bad phone out just
you know like an LA you you work tons of
collaboration some color just dissipate
right and you put pictures together you
know they bite disappear and and this
guy didn't work out
parted ways really don't see him for a
long long time and then a similar
project comes with not it but
it was about me basically was like who's
gonna do a project about me didn't work
out some other people want to do a
project about the podcasts I've been
doing now so about me but different and
again it's my life like you know when
you know you don't know get the rights
to your life in perpetuity for the whole
rest of your life so this guy finds out
not gonna work with him again it's been
ten years since either and I know this
person they're not in a good place
things haven't worked out for 10 years
they're very they're angry they're
frustrated you look at their other
content this person in particular
mooched after their family but then [__]
talked them all the time to just an
angry person not getting what they want
in the world but not doing dick about it
in a positive way just [__] hating
hating hating and then now that person's
exactly that person who creates fake
aliases to threaten and harass me and my
wife you know like that you know just
I'm like and I think of him now when I
see other troll comments on the web I'm
like I know you I know you this is about
this is you this isn't about me well all
the [__] you're saying when you're that
angry it's about you you know that
person that person is so [__]
miserable and unhappy with their life
that it would be hard to step back and
take you know some [__]
responsibility and be a man
and be like you know what I made some
[__] terrible choices I was lazy I
didn't do this I didn't do that
that takes some balls I take some like
self-awareness and painful self reflects
much easier to be like men everybody's
just trying to [__] me over and the
world [__] sucks
and everybody who gets ahead they're a
piece of [__] because they [__] over
other people to do that so [__] you and
[__] that person like something there
those opinions mean nothing to be
excited I just think about this one
person like are you just a version of
this dude yep I'm like I know you I know
who you are and I know that personal Oh
cuz that was that person at one time
yeah yeah angry frustrated I couldn't
figure out how to get right right away
you know yes you're on the [__] world
it's not the world war [__] right what
did you do this morning between 8:00 and
10:00
oh yeah and sat there watch the cogito
or whatever the game is right what's the
name of that man right The Price is
Right
Wow looking for a job were you right hey
did any of these things know you wanna
watch The Price is Right
yeah no I'm go watch the prices [__]
right right right wake up at 8:00 and
you really really in your heart feel
that you work that day yeah
a year and doing that you won't be
frustrated right you're frustrated
because you're just not doing what
you're supposed to be doing and it's a
win if you've been frustrated yeah you
know Danny I got you by 20 years yeah I
used to you start thinking about the
manifestation of feelings that you've
had in your life like I'm writing a book
I'm trying to that's awesome I'll be
buying it I'll be buying it
manifestation you start understanding
the manifestations that you went through
from a certain ages it's [__] scary
and you don't feel like they're part of
your life you feel like they were part
of another way yeah yeah yeah feel like
that deja vu you feel all these things
you feel guilt
yes I feel all these feelings because
you see the manifestations of things you
know my dad died when I was three
there was an insecurity and then the
immigrant thing that turned into a
different insecurity manifestation in
New York can't speak English
oye hello you know look at spit boy you
know and then and then I got wheels and
Jersey and I started going but those
feelings were still there and then your
mother dies and right you're a Catholic
and you really really believe in God and
you really believe in the Holy Ghost you
really believe and you've tried to do
everything right to that agent now you
question God and now you're you're
[__] killing cats you're running over
pigeons you know you see how a mouse you
step on it there's a certain anger you
get and then like I look at Malloy and
it went from sorrow became anger to
became fury yeah
fury Furies when there's a homeless guy
in the corner
you just went up to him and kick him in
the [__] head for no reason while
he's sleeping nothing I take the
homeless guy in the head I'm just saying
yeah I know what it's like yeah to see
somebody and go I want to just stab that
person right they didn't do anything to
you we see it every day in the news yeah
somebody gets killed but that somebody
who's going that's somebody that that
manifestation went to fury then I got
happy that I went to prison and actually
on a prison yeah and it made me happy
cuz it slowed everything down and let me
process all those manifestations then I
went out into the real world yeah Harry
then I got divorced I lost a child and
now you're angry again but I'm that I
had calmly slowly anger manifested it
would manifest for 23 hours except for
the one hour dad did comedy I would be
happy because yeah so you start looking
at the manifestations of your feelings
and how you just go so when I see these
people that write a negative comment or
[__] you and your podcast right what man
there's a thousand things I don't like
but I don't have the balls to go on
Twitter and go hey I don't like your
podcasts I just don't have the balls I
know that that person is trying very
hard I know that right yeah you just
keep it to yourself
you know yeah that's why I said I want I
had won one with it with a heckler years
ago and it's only the only time this
works this way but this guy he came in I
don't know he came in late to the show
everybody was having fun and he just
didn't like it you know he was just
causing problems so you know I don't
know 30 40 minutes I'm like - what's
going on man what's with your [__]
you know funny and I just and I - stop
I'm like you know what man I'm like
everyone was having a good time here I'm
like you're not having a good time I'm
like you know what I do when I'm not
having a good time and like a movie or
some place I [__] leave you remember
when you came in here and they nailed
your ass to the seat and they told you
they'd [__] execute you if you tried
to leave early now that never happened
you could just walk away right now then
you get to go do something that you like
I get it I'm like I don't think I'm
funny all the time like there's plenty
things that I think is funny I'm like I
don't have to be for everybody I don't
need to be for you but you don't have to
be here and it was like a little
lightbulb he just kind of any [__]
got up and he left and I just wish more
people because that same thing there's
plenty stuff that I don't like but then
I just don't look at it I can't tell you
I don't watch the 80s and yeah exactly
Robin
n-never so I'm not gonna waste another
hour never side boycotted Tom Hanks
tears when he cried at the Oscars what
do you want the Philadelphia with the
spots on
knocking [__] and he won a boycott him
Marlon Brando sent an Indian when he won
the [__] guy right he didn't [__]
cry on the Oscars gonna cry boycotted
Tom Hanks for bunny ears I didn't have a
petition sign what brought you back
[Laughter]
Boyka chasse 416 inline detour behavior
I will boycott your eyes Thank You Sara
there was somebody else I boycott I
boycotted a couple people my time just
for different [__] acts writing in a
song comics a boycott of common sure
right yeah that was one comic I knew in
love for 20 years he had an opening joke
that was funny 20 years ago and he got a
shot at a TV spot yeah and he did the
joke old joke boys got it I brought this
phone don't even call no more [__]
I bumped into my size change your number
I don't even talk to I actually like
them you boycott them for six months and
kept it to the six month date I'll put
it the book picture like a board boycott
like Oh February 12th you like printed
out little pictures of the people that
you boycott you [__] come on the
board you guys date under it boycott it
i well yeah right a restaurant I see
fingerprints on the glass when you push
the glass in that means you didn't wash
your [__] that means you know if you
can't wipe the glass down if eight
employees are there and they can't wipe
the glass at night and sense the
fingerprints that means you guys don't
wash your hands after you pee and yeah
yeah yeah then after a woman here don't
watch this match after one of these
Mexican bow Busboys shoots a load of
[__]
the mentos and they're [__] they
don't worship so I don't want to do
business with you that's it it's that
easy and I refuse to go back in there
and yeah go Joey but
they don't clean the glass right like i
Boyd concert like if you eat ranch
dressing you can't sit at the table I
love you that that go over there with
your friends and when you're finished
like a Tom over here now just paste you
like Tom Hanks eating some [__] ranch
yeah taking him back on the boy ranch
over there
you want to eat hummus go whenever your
friends don't sit at this table because
I am NOT talking to you Leah how is i've
been boycotted a few times if I ever see
him put a chip in hummus in front of me
look I never did Co control him out of
the chair I never would do coke around
Joe yeah I know he loved me that much
and it bothered him his soul to see me
coked up yeah see to someone he was
around number a homebrewer I wanna do a
line
no no no much coke I had respect yes I
was raised I think you only caught me
twice doing coconut yeah even make eye
contact yeah yeah because I knew I would
let him down now Lee has that hummus
respect you I help people out some
comics have come in here with like
snacks
you're like trust me it's not worth it
it's just oh no I won't I have I used to
have a friend that used to that's who
used to call it 86 in year yeah yeah 68
68 in 1668 86 you don't what I mean I
say 80 system well he told me one time I
said Eric if the guy was looking for ya
Eric I go Erica's looking for you this
no no 86 panic yeah yeah you can that
Michael came from me no Michael damn
you're a cold-blooded [__] like
your uncle Joey
yeah boycott people I love it
not a ton of people but there's
definitely been a I coming up more like
in comedy is a I started to worry about
like meeting some of the acts I admired
or whatever cuz my thing was always just
are they a nice person and I know like a
nice person can have an off day be
grouchy whatever but the
sometimes when people just do things
that are just like dick moves and I
won't say his name you know there was
one guy worked with you know a long time
ago but he he pretended that the the
college I was working at with him open
it up for him he act like the kids told
him to tell me to cut some jokes out of
my act and to cut my time and I went to
them later turns out it was not true at
all he just didn't like it and he wanted
to kind of like he's in like and he did
and this isn't cocky at all he didn't
like that I did well even though he did
better than me like he had nothing to be
insecure about and I just thought man
this is somebody who is you know selling
out steers already at this point I'm
like you're gonna I was just you know I
drove off my hon died [__] hatchback
you know I'm used to making a hundred
bucks a night and stuff like that and
you're gonna take what little thing I
have just to have fun on stage for
fifteen minutes away from me because you
didn't like that guy I went I threw away
his [__] albums never listened to him
since I got boycotted him for 15 plus
years but I'm just like [__] you you
[__] [__] and I got after that the
bully type thing people use powers again
that's the stuff where I'm like you to
be crazy yeah you're dead to me
well that was a feature act I had a lot
of problems as a feature just people
couldn't follow you and then they and
then they talk [__] about you I said the
Omni pop cruel oh yeah me oh my god
they've got that name those
[__] alive because Omni pop had
a good book yeah at a time but he was
taking feature acts and trying to make
him into headline yeah why we must all
around today I mean I know you're
talking about yeah and I would go on
those b-roll routes and then him to
follow me and I would light him on fire
and I would lie them on fire you know 20
minutes no responsibilities you're a
dead man you never saying right I got a
package in my pocket I've been talking
on one of the waitresses you know yeah
suck dick you see it's done you know
yeah but I'm the pop was putting out you
know to these feature acts and right
right I'm old-school I'm very old-school
and here's the rule I have you want MC
you got it
you want a feature you got it but why
don't you consider yourself a headlining
one complaint
out of your mouth I don't want to hear
that Dan Cummings talks to the audience
oh right right right here that Dan
Kammen this is too dirty right I don't
want to hear that Dan Cummings you once
you sign that contract the headline Dan
calmness comes out and says with a
drumroll and takes his pants off and
takes a flare right and sticks it in his
ass and does a half hour of playing the
drums of the flats [__] solid closing
I better figure out how that you know
who's gonna follow that [__] Jesus
can't follow if I went onstage ripped my
pants off suck a flare up my ass with
Vaseline but I in the word like yeah I'm
gonna do presentation a little flair and
just want excuse me ladies and gentlemen
took my pants all right put a flare in
my ass yeah lit it on fire and then
started playing the snare drum right
women right until you heard this no one
was that what comic would wanna follow
that they couldn't you know you'd have
to have your dick do your act to follow
that your dick would have known you'd
have to go on stage and go Oh ready for
this one get a [__] what do you think
meat tenderizing who runs this
[__] I Do's out of this hose
house what some expression I don't know
whatever the [__] movie does he hit
himself but I would you know nothing's
bothered me more I got a ham I got ten
commas that would go to management
yeah and complained behind my back that
they would I had one guy that told me I
couldn't improvise I couldn't talk to
the audience I could be dirt oh my god
and I finally turned to him on Friday
told him exactly how I felt good for you
and if he didn't like it [__] quit
and if we wanted to throw hands let's do
it until this day he's never spoken to
me again well I could care less I've had
yeah I've had comics Ted have tried to
get me in trouble during the week they
didn't think I know
bump into one the island before why
brother Mon stay oh wow that's so long
yeah actually mentioned that did you
know how I work on stage before you buy
him up on stage right last time I saw
this guy in it and it made me it just
made me think that when if I ever got to
that level yet would never act that and
I am proud that I am proud yeah I've
never asked somebody to change anything
about their act I've never told the club
to ask them to change I've never said
don't sell don't come up to this just do
your time that's the only thing I won't
take your time and do whatever the [__]
you want you I mean it and I've had
people ask me like now I'm you know
bring John Hawke or Mary Santora and
different people around to open and it's
great but you know sometimes the first
time to work with you're like hey is
there anything
I almost feel I feel bad I feel but
they're asking that's because clearly
that they have somebody else that
they've worked with has told them not to
do something what's happened to me you
know early on tuned I'm like no no I'm
like I've always [__] hated that it's
like don't worry you do what you do your
stuff I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna talk
about what I want to talk about when I
get out there I'm not finally sometimes
about comedy yeah I'm very rough only
because Lee knows I look at this is a
religion this is the religion that saved
me Christianity in the same way the
Jehovah's didn't save me
you know Catholics didn't say I mean
this is a real religion if you look at
it yeah one thing you know I love when I
go into a club and the host comes up to
me and he calls me mr. Diaz right there
he already lost it right because we're
comics there's no mr. Diaz and then they
say is there anything particularly wrong
they're saying I look on the face lying
or nothing and their expression it's
like I took 20 pounds off and right I
know if I know anything about comedy
yeah I know that they're just trying to
remember their own jokes yep for
Christ's sake why are you picking on me
yeah well I'm just trying to remember my
jokes you want me to get there now and
talk about your guest appearance on will
ya a fright right and how you did The
Tonight Show eight times with Letterman
and without Letterman and how you one
stud you know just [__] it and then if
you
messin up on Thursday oh my god Lee
excuse me can I see you after the show
uh hi dad
it's Diaz Diaz right you say that real
quick right right yes Diaz it's a
syllable deal yeah yeah and I know you
[__] Hatter oh yeah so when that's
done to you you go happy yeah the first
thing you say to yourself is I'm not
saying I'm gonna be a feature but if I
do become a feature act I'm not gonna
treat right you got guys exactly then
when I became the feature yeah I started
getting that hush treatment the only one
that said something to me that backed
his words why that I don't mind if and I
told this to him May 1 and I told this
to people and here's another problem we
have and I did it too when you work with
a popular headliner a very good
headliner has a feature or or an emcee
right and you start doing it for a while
guess what happens
oh yeah yeah if they pick up your
cadence and it's our sound and like you
that's that's yeah that that warrants a
discussion right okay right right
the saying [__] the same little things
that they don't know they're saying but
they're saying it mean a LipPerfection
all right well I don't really know stop
saying that because Richard Jeni came up
to me he goes jokes that was a very much
he just taught me how to write yeah yeah
he just talked me out of right I can't
do the joke about the one-legged
[__] right right cuz you follow me
yeah yeah yeah the bit is too strong
yeah that's right right I'll tell me I
can't improvise right listen there's a
school of thought they're trying to
sabotage your bank
is improvising now the audience will
talk to me when I go on stage that's the
other train of thought
my train of thought now is I'm such a
professional gum my bass is so strong
then I'll shut the heckler down like if
you onstage
yeah yeah yeah you ever work with New
York comics oh yeah you work somebody to
be here how you doing hey what do you do
for a living yeah sure
you came with him oh no [__] what he's
right right you do you guys know each
other
that's 5050 work yeah 50% of that
sometimes you get under standing
ovations yeah house it'll be a long
night but what happens now you trained
the audience to talk so the headliner so
I go up there now for 10 minutes he's
gonna deal with chitchat you just steam
right through and they know you're not
[__] about right exactly right right
it'll time for in my base my presence
right the first one all that stuff's in
security like are you talking about the
people that you know that needs a very
specific introduction and you can't say
this it's all about they're just same
thing they're super insecure I never
worked with the guy who did the very
long but I've heard horror stories of
like the hand guy there's one guy I
don't really remember his name cuz I
never met him I just heard about it from
a few other people that he printed out
this long back of their guy and expected
people to memorize it it was like this
ridiculous [__] like you may love like
the Simpsons like you may remember him
from but it was like you met you know
you've seen him on this show this show
this show he's been on you know Conan
three times and he was in this movie and
that movie but it was like [__] 15
sangs and and if you [__] it up I
guess this guy would like go off on
people [__] it that's crazy that's got
the lunatic you good audience doesn't
care
they don't [__] care they just want
you to be funny I have one thing I say
the time when people ask I say one thing
the host of time suck just mention my
podcast that is it's and sometimes it
would you only see Comedy Central make
no I don't [__] care and they don't
care they just want to hear what jokes I
have and they're gonna like him whether
or not but they're not gonna leave going
man I'm sure glad I saw that guy who's
on Conan twice oh that's so great what
are the greatest experiences I had was
the host 18 months I was in the house
most of the triple game Oh which one I I
did so may those I didn't do that one
older this is gone before yeah yeah you
was still playing with a handball
this Algren why you had one hair on your
nutsack or the rest of it was coming up
and I started and when you got that one
little patch of hair over the first day
oh [__] ah [__] start and then you got
two hairs and you're like oh [__]
pussy's on the way then the sides filled
in the side I'll beat some ass and no
time I had like a little mustache about
my dad but that little bald spot stayed
ball for a long time
yeah you had you had a yeah no man come
on you're sick came in opposite I guess
mine came in on the side too I came in
on the sides first and then the bush I
took the long time I had a rub Rogaine
on it before was Rogaine you had a mix
like gasoline do piss I remember the
little thin dusting up up top it was
just a little dusting yeah but when you
looked at it look like a boy in the
mirror was born sad you're sad so you
couldn't take a hat you couldn't show up
it's a showing up with three bullets
well you got six spaces you were showing
up with a nice dick and like a bozo
hairdo with the bald spot the middle but
that bald spot took forever you
estimated you're like okay it's June
14th this I'll be ready to get my dick I
remember I was super late action I went
to a small school I do remember now that
they were talking about this PE I don't
even think kids like necessarily are in
the shower in the locker room all naked
together anymore but it might like you
know I was going to school like
everybody's negative and I was like I
was the last kid like everybody I had
nothing little Baldy I had a weird I
didn't grow at all from like fourth
grade to about eighth grade and by the
time eighth grade I was the smallest kid
in my class boy or girl and I just hit
and then puberty hit like I hit very
late so I just member that's what my
memories had just been like a [__]
nothing still
and I remember panicking thinking I was
just never gonna have it I didn't get
bullet I was 14
what my legs have oh yeah I'm 1p no I'm
with I think I got one little long
[__] hair I got enough
they don't have threes you braid them
now I'm losing my hair on top but my
eyebrows have been on fire they've been
on a growth spurt like this times I'll
find an eyebrow just [__] gravitate
I'll tell my wife to cut him before I go
on the road and wasn't you know you were
born arrow that we Jota has that good
mirror yeah look all right yes I see
hairs coming out of my ears
I'm losing the hair on my doll well your
hair looks good I mean from this angle
although your hair lines low oh the
headlights low but look at the eyebrows
they're on fire Sally I like Elvis's
hairdo when he was 21
well he got out of the service they're
on fire I've been thinking I've been
going bald for my whole adult life
that's high it's a high hairline it's
definitely a little thinner for sure
but what's funny is I just looked at our
date I was like man it's definitely
going now it's finally going and then I
looked at a thing from like five years
ago and I'm like oh [__] I thought was
going then and then I looked at the
picture of like 10 years ago my high
school history teacher like a sophomore
year he was like he was bald and he was
like ah you don't got much time left
like he thought but yeah just high high
I always had this crazy high hairline
III was prompt propecia in middle school
no oh it kills your dick so they took me
off of it well you propecia minute you
start going bald middle school oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah I was by was come up
like I was gone by like 25 I was gone
yes you got you got a solid shaved head
though lucky what they I think it's
weird but I also I've also always had I
have shoulder hair back hair but leg
here I have hair everywhere else
everywhere in it like it gets where I
got to back shavers in case one goes
because it's terrible you want is good
you just wanna shave you squirrely yeah
just glued up that is so good it looks
like they're doesn't know we grow I
don't know what's out look that's alpha
I don't know why nobody's ever thought
of that put the ball hair on their head
ball hair leg head put all on patch is
fine it's don't put it into the stem
itself don't try to grow it just crazy
that crazy ball hair on the head I look
at Willie Willie if I do that
and I was told my hair last night a
visual I can't believe I'm losing my
head but I need you know I wasn't and I
wasn't a handsome guy growing up so I
couldn't be bald thank God at least I
had hair like throw that say well at
least the guys got hair he's got a nice
big and eats my ass all these fits in my
[__] he does nasty things you know
you're not a good look nasty things in
bed yeah good-looking guys just bring
you home and [__] you and flex their
chests and they come on you and they
call you a dirty [__] I couldn't do
that I was luckily dude honey yes and
getting them flip you over make them
tell you I jerk off to your pet fat
little pictures and all that [__] ha ha
you got a towel [__] you gotta work that
why are you squinting over to your wife
try not to say thanks yeah yeah she says
good won't you Drummond oh my god it's
pretty good man actually actually my
wife and I we just uh we started the
podcast that'll launch in a few weeks
I'm a horror fan so uh I love horror
before comedy actually like a horror
movies my favorite Stephen King all that
kind of stuff and I just love a scary
okay I got you first guest yeah well you
know our structure is just I just find
these stories and then you put them in
my kind of narrative voice but I just
tried to scare she just know the story's
gonna be we sit in the dark studio with
a bunch of a cult candle [__] around us
it's [__] creepy room and I just try
to scare the [__] out of her with two
stories a week so that's a that's the
new way and then the and then the other
podcast has been going well man and the
torrents going well you see the trailer
for that new tip that trailers here
honey I haven't seen the trailer I don't
watch TV I saw a bus bench the other day
that was creepy that's one with the
clown yeah
Pennywise Pennywise so bad you know
clowns had a parade after that no the I
saw that why for real dog after that
movie came out clowns had a
demonstration now like when I want out
creepy
without creepy because of what you
clowns started losing work
that movie came out they started getting
cancelled for magicians good and [__]
like Marvel Comics so a bunch of
magicians went downtown and protested
that movie bill yeah we're losing all
their summer work that was one of the
funniest a nice [__] I read in my
life a bunch of guys with like rubbing
noses with sticks and big feet [__]
saying listen come on give us a break
you're not creepy me to meet you I don't
know what it is about clouds I have a
clown store I did it on an album years
ago but it's all true true story I hated
clowns cuz I had the craziest clown
story I was always watching movies being
a horror stuff you know my parents
weren't paying attention whatever like
that or mom would be gone I would just
first thing I do with my HBO and just
see what I could watch and I watched
that movie poltergeist you know with the
one with the little girl she died later
yeah little girl and there's a there's a
clown uh ventriloquist clown doll in
that movie under the boy's bed remember
that lead and try I would never see that
okay tries to strangle him when the
house goes crazy and it's all and
there's a poltergeist activity in the
house this this this ventriloquist oh
well that wasn't a prop made for that
movie that was an actual ventriloquist
clown doll that you could buy the store
that I had that was like my favorite toy
for whatever reason prior to that movie
and I had it in my room so I [__] see
that but I don't want to tell my parents
because I'll get in trouble for watching
some was supposed to watch so I just
take the clown doll and I take him
downstairs like little kid mentality and
I [__] beat the [__] out of them like
I just you know I hooked his old clown
thing like hung him around the doorknobs
this [__] worked in like [__]
stupid clown [__] you can't give me
whatever like throw him in the trash
think I killed him I'll go to bed my mom
found the clown doll in the trash and
thought it was just misplaced so she
doesn't know that I'm terrified and she
puts that [__] back in my room on like
a little chair so then I wake up in the
middle of night and I see that son of a
[__] back in the room like he's [__]
watching me and it it gave me
reoccurring nightmares for [__] years
like I was paralyzed and I still want to
get in trouble I so afraid that I
[__] dealt with it for several like
like days until finally I broke down
there for the whip last year but they
get this podcast some raw the [__]
associations and I come after you
beating up a little [__] accountant
that will you would ten years and then
your arguments gonna be I didn't beat up
a [__] I see the dog am I gonna say
could have a difference what have you
had a cocktails do you know your doll
story triggered me I always hated those
ventriloquist doll kinda cream I like
this when I first met Duncan he had a
been a little homo whatever hold on
and he's bring him on the road with us
and Doug I would make sure I was on the
floor with him like I would tell them at
the desk don't put me on the same floor
with him seriously it creeped you out
that much just don't like all that [__]
you have like my grandma had all those
weird porcelain dolls around the house
you have something like that around
where you grew up like a bunch of dolls
they're creepy oh I hate those cuz I
broke one of my mother's da long time a
little Japanese dollar you switch the
wigs on I don't know I think I know it's
like porcelain porcelain yeah my father
okay okay yeah told me that to throw the
ball in the house when I broke the
[__] doll I tried to Krazy Glue the
[__] helmers glue back the doll again
looked like somebody came on the bow and
about like we're thinking about it now I
think of doll would come on it I hadn't
[__] I'll miss goo all over her [__]
my mom's like what happened to my dog
and I had a pain out of my pocket I
don't know what it is I just I've never
been hip to clowns what about that
statue you had when he came home at
night I had this statue in my house this
is San Lazaro this is like one of the
patron saint to Cuba
okay and my mother believed so much in
my father that they had a six foot
statue [__] in the house so
whether you opened the door of the
living room
he was in between the kitchen and the
[__] living room and never nights
that I would come down to get water acid
I would open my door he had a gold crown
he had a gold crown oh yeah and two
crutches if you go to my house I still
have crutches in my house when I got my
knee operated out of respect for this
saint is a view Cuban you have to you
have to celebrate the same from December
17 but like two weeks before my mother
died I had a party and had Eber Ali and
his boys
work them but the red devil was then he
was he took one of the crutches from the
saint and he goes you take one more step
and I hit you over the head with this
[__] crutch
so it's redness that's what I think
about I'm sorry the joy you know it was
our candles and stuff underneath no no
no no candles nothing the offering is uh
you had a purple cape if you see a cube
per person dressed like a purple they
made a promise they made the promised
for their knees or okay this yeah you
know when when uh when that's why you
can't hit a dog if you're Cupid that's
why what Michael Vick got sentenced to
prison there were a couple of prisoners
they couldn't put them in because they
were Harbor cause in those prison and
they dedicate their life to this Saint
Wow so you got help dogs and stuff like
me the other night I don't know if I
told you Lee the analyte son they done a
lot of the comedy stuff I get in my
little Subaru I started up looking gold
reverse yeah yeah yeah what's that dog
dog two feet and he's like six feet from
me line lower the window Mike are you
doing this neighborhood [__]
are you lost and I'm like uh Pete don't
come here I'm started talk to him in
Spanish because of my Cuban roots and
next thing you know I realized that's
not a dog that's coyote my window when I
call my wife and go get out of here
I just put the car in reverse it went
backwards like that dude that robbed the
cop car and date yesterday I didn't know
that robbed the cop car backwards ever
chase him he's doing 90 miles
holy [__] nineteen Rockwoods yeah end up
killing the family it's a [__] shame
but I [__] went back the last three
nights I've seen that [__] coyote I
saw
Sunday Monday and Tuesday night but my
neighborhood is going crazy you think
the Crips moved into town oh excuse me
the coyote wolf its Kyle I saw some
white dude run I pulled up this and I
got dog IOT cuz those studio city
streets are dark yeah they're [__]
dark like if I go to leave Street in the
middle
that's the easiest place to mug somebody
like if you're looking to rape somebody
just go to [__] what are you Addison
Addison in between Koufax and Laurel
Canyon
that's rapist paradise there that's like
rapist paradise you should you hide
under a bush in the third block you can
rape on a [__] a little boy a [__] a
woman and get out of there within
minutes I've told the cops that any
officer he talks about I told the cop
one day cuz there was uh there was a
home invasion a block away from Colfax
grammar school and I saw a cop on my
block my god I'm slapped on down my gold
would you do me a favor do you mind
going down around this block a lot more
it looks like what do you thought oh my
god
I've lived in this house for a year and
a half were stymied see he's coming down
this block we have a security service
yeah that he belongs to the school so we
rent him also and he does patrols but I
trust him like I trust Lee was a gunman
I'm saying yeah he's just a guy that
they gave a job to fade dollars if I
tell Lee to watch my house and he sees
three [__] burglaries what are we
gonna do beat him up nah he's gonna
shoot him call 9-1-1 that's what this
guy has to do yeah so I told the cops I
want some house I go this is like one of
the [__] best neighborhoods around
and there's no streetlights
I'll go in between like with Alicia used
to live how many times I would take
Felicia home at night and I almost hit
somebody walking a dog is that dark huh
and probably because it's a nice
neighborhood they don't want to it
it ruins the aesthetic or something you
aesthetic that's well that's what
they'll say they don't have sidewalks in
the neighborhoods no it's crazy
Studio City North Hollywood that
crossover yeah my neighborhood that's
like [__] I'm happy my block that the
two blocks east because of the school we
have that security in the security parks
on my corner so he see me any parks
right there because that's a parking lot
for the school so I'm pretty lucky but
what about to be before blocks on me
what about the people across Riverside
like where Felicia's used to live I
don't try
I used to drive Felicia yeah and make
sure she get the door that's how much I
don't trust and also yeah I'll have an
Idaho now and it is funny just thinking
I'm like oh yeah
like that we'll have these stocks
anymore because there's there's no
sidewalks and so many of the
neighborhoods there and like so much of
it is just dark it's just you just like
it I don't like oh yeah Steven loves
your door when you left your house I
don't know like could could not oh you
you I mean you could I mean play my
dukes I'm a little more paranoid than
that so we left but you could I mean you
could yeah yeah here by the hole you
coeur d'alene okay so that's just be in
place yeah you know it's funny I don't
do any of the stuff that you're supposed
to do that I don't ski on snowboarding
instead I don't have all the boys
yes oh yeah my my son and daughter duh
they want to get into I think they want
to get a new vibe skiing some event see
Monroe my daughter my daughter does have
you lived in quality be the mom you
asked
we've been up there three years and then
[__] skied yet max I haven't done it
I know I gotta take him I took the money
kids they don't want a ski they weren't
try but they they what do we do you know
what's funny there they like to be home
did we do like a lot of uh like they're
always doing like lessons of some kind
or some kind of sports so I want to say
on top of all that stuff stuff they just
want to like be home have you taken so
much easier tubing is the best cuz
tubing and on to what we're on yellow my
god there's a huge sled hill we do that
we do that that's easy just to go down
you know but even on that like yeah we
did it a couple times a year
yeah that's fun but uh yeah I got I'm
gonna actually do the snowboarding your
skin but it is beautiful up there we do
like you know it's just nice like get
out in the lake or bike rides or you
know hikes and whatever or just drive
beyond the yard I mean honestly we have
a trampoline in the back house the best
I don't know what 300 bucks spent my
life
like they just want to go do those kind
of things yeah dogs you happy I am you
know we got a nice like we have a little
podcast studio that is literally less
than two minute drive from my house so
get up in the morning go down there we
got a couple employees now that's what
we do in time sock what we're gonna do
are scared to death thing so it's like a
family business we have a couple people
to work for us that we really like and
it's just easy you know it's like yes
sir I mean I had to like you know except
that I'm not gonna be able to you know
go on auditions or things like that but
I really wasn't doing that anyone I
that's not what I I never cared about
that just for me I like to stand like I
still do stand-up back she's going
better than ever because of the podcast
getting more my fans to the shows than I
ever did when I lived here so for me
it's worked out I wouldn't recommend it
for any for everybody you know if
somebody really wants to you know be in
a scene and and come up that way and be
part of that or if they're really into
like trying to act or trying to write or
trying to produce I mean you got except
you're not gonna do that kind of stuff
but you know but the game has changed so
much so to what's random is I do like
Skype auditions I don't even try to do
auditions but everyone something wants
you for a host or something Skype it's
great if you don't need sleep yeah you
don't yeah yeah you know I come down
everyone snow off from meetings and
stuff and even on that stuff I just I
love doing I love have my own business
and I love kind of being my own brand
now and I just want to like go further
with that so for me I love it and it
gives me more time I love to like write
and create stuff like that and I'm not
sitting in traffic I'm not I just get to
you know beta office is set up like I
like it's an environment conducive to me
being creative a bunch of weird [__] on
the walls all that kind of stuff
and it's it's great but it would drive
some people [__] crazy get the work
out of there during the week is there
anywhere to go and do call me during the
week no but you know what I never did
that much when I was down here either
it's like I like to think think think
console and then I uh the last couple
albums I've made have all just been from
the road just throwing stuff in the
middle yeah I never just I think it's
because where I started there wasn't
that option where in Spokane okay when I
got in so I basically my open mics were
kind of like tribal gigs I I did a
little bit of these rooms in Spokane
like these uh weekend rooms and then
tribal was desperate for features that
would be willing to drive people to all
these Montana gigs and Idaho gigs and
all that kind of stuff and so looking
back I didn't realize how crazy it was
and I had a guitar early on which I end
up dropping like four years in but I got
all this road time in these weird little
bars all over the northwest and I just
learned to develop new bits in that
atmosphere and then that just became
part of my process and then I started
featuring in clubs and stuff same thing
I would just every week it was a goal to
get a new bit to work and that stuck in
my head and then and then it was when I
went to LA I had kids I went to LA came
to LA after I was divorced so my kids
were here you know I had to be with them
the whole time and when I wasn't with
them the whole time I was doing gigs in
the road the whole time so just never
fit lifestyle wise to really work things
out on a regular basis in the club so I
just never develop that well yet know
what you should be special when you're
new special way it's gonna be yeah -
October 17th I think it's it's a crow
foot ballroom it's like a little rock
club and Pontiac Michigan little suburb
of Detroit and yeah I think I think I
think it's almost I mean it's not a big
place but you know I wanted something
different well part of it was markets
we'd already burned you know because
there was and then markets we'd already
filmed that we just want to do something
different and I've like recorded stuff
in Portland Oregon Salt Lake City and
Spokane Washington and Minneapolis and
and last time I was through Detroit I
said a blast and just but a lot of it
was like routing worked out well you
know routing there's a there's a couple
other cities that maybe like the next
time around you know Denver I love but
but we already had Denver kind of on the
books by the time we decided to kind of
try and do the special so so mostly was
based on venue availability honestly out
of markets that I liked we looked at
Atlanta and then in Detroit with the
final two and then Detroit just gave us
that great Lisa V I've had a blast it's
always every time I've been there I've
had a blast I've had a great time in the
whole state of Michigan yeah you know
state of Michigan is oh yeah you know
they talk about you at a doctor grins
yeah Bob yeah I love those guys I love
those it's a fun place hi was there
Rapids economy yeah did from Niles I did
from it's called Niles Michigan which is
really calm miss your wife yeah I don't
know I've been Indiana okay so you play
Notre Dame yeah I've done all the way
from Missha wocka all the way up to ish
mommy what is useful mean I mean nothing
I mean is the tip where it's [__]
penguin weather all year round all that
and then you got Mackinac Island
oh yeah wouldn't what I was it's a big
vacation place in the late 90s I say 30%
of my road work was in the state of
Michigan the other 30 intact Wow wow
that's random taxes you could build you
could live in taxes was there like a
David Tribble of Texas or when you were
doing clubs in Texas Texas I was doing
no at the time I wasn't in Texas at all
there was a guy named initials he fired
me early on I told to suck my dick
because he would give you he would sign
you up for five nights then the week of
Aggie call you'd pay those two hats yet
and it's Thursday and Thursday so what
am i Tuesday and Friday
you make what am I supposed to do for
three nights all the way out and [__]
Tucson Arizona yeah walk to the [__]
gig TJ something so I I moved to Seattle
and I called him like a man and I told
him that I couldn't do the gig cuz yeah
cause you took it if you cancel you'll
never work an improv again and I said
okay and then the night of the gig I
said nobody threatens uncle Joey and I
waited till 7 o'clock he texts me ten
minutes out and he goes ok while you're
in Seattle right I'm gonna Seattle then
he called back and he goes why the [__]
are you know where I am I'm in Seattle
you ever threaten me again I'm getting a
Kong but on and not too far I just want
our [__] you that's funny you'll never
work again you'll never work an improv
yeah that's great because of Houston he
had a Rockville Mississippi and it was
open somebody said they're looking for
headliner I called him I got just to see
and he goes what's your name I told me
no man your name sounds familiar to me
because it was call me tomorrow I'll let
you know and the next day I called my
new you remember who I am because I
never forgot who the [__] you I go still
20 years later [__] you
I had Tribble in those days but I also
had the Grand Rapids guy John Yoda
yeah Otis yeah yeah Yoda was very very
very good to me oh that's great
I only know his their sons right Jamie
saying those got yeah the first time
they gave me a check they had tears in
their eyes the first time the sons it
was the biggest check I've ever received
oh you had tears oh because they were so
happy for ya yeah to me saying they're
sad they had to give you that much money
you could say I love the deck Apple was
it was the very beginning of the podcast
yeah and what for people who don't know
the legend the Floyd Mayweather is from
Grand Rapids Michigan
so I Philips oh yes and the Floyd stones
copy
I thought your yeah I think around the
comic I missed the kid yeah oh he's a
good boy yeah so like maybe God rest his
soul before well a lot of people don't
know it's got the more churches per
capita in the country huh so the to Yoda
boys who were sweethearts believed that
dirty calmly wouldn't do well so they
laughed at my agent they laughed at
anybody
in fact they learned the hard way
because they think they got Leno for the
comedy festival Graham rep oh yeah Gilda
faster way yeah I'm gonna take you to
something that's a [__] working-class
community
who's gonna pay a yardstick to see Jay
Leno that was 20 years ago
Elvis is dead I don't feel something
myself and I'm saying so when I they
call for me there was two clubs that
laughed at me it was them and Caroline's
okay
and they really laughed at me Caroline
Scott was like Diaz is important he's
like um he's a ham and Egger but Grand
Rapids was like well book them but dirty
comedy doesn't fly over here so they
went ahead and gave me like 90% of the
door oh that's awesome and you killed it
and when they had to give me that check
on Saturday night you could see them
like the head was down like it was like
they had tears in their eyes they didn't
call my manager back like a month they
didn't want to hear my name but you
cannot you know there was a lot of cop
comedy clubs like that Dan Hawass was
like that he changes to he's my brother
today he stubs oh yeah man I love Keith
I love he brought Doug Stan open in 2001
and the Chamber of Commerce went [__]
nuts they wrote a letter they accused to
closing down I mean it was funny yeah
well he was fighting that the culture
there a long time he was very scared
yeah I only called him in 2014 I said
hey al you know it was a long time ago
right right we shot yeah he goes I also
work so he put me in the little room oh
yeah
at the X of the big room and it was like
he's like I'm sorry can you stay for
sadly and I'm like I can't because he
thought it wasn't gonna work but he's a
nice guy
yeah yeah he's great it was the guys
that were like negative about it the
Yoder's one is negative for sure make
sure yeah but there's a lot of people
dirty Tommy will not work on a market
right and you'd be [__] surprised
that funny comedy works yeah and
everybody works and everyone yeah yeah
it's really weird what you go through at
every level whether yancy a feature or a
[__] head like a still go through
[__] that I mean that duh Orange
County don't lie on me what homie magic
la oh well yeah they won't have a very
bottom I was very happy because at least
they called me and told me to my face
yeah yeah like men instead of me I'm
email then yeah a little email yeah
they're rare club that way they're a
rare client very good eye catcher and
the guys down there but they have a
different eye and I used to do spots
here and there but then and with me to
they'd be like hey but you can't you
know you got to do very clean above the
blah they had they have a very rare
business model and good for them where
they can pack that room just kind of
regardless you know or at least I used
to used to just be like a good nice
people and they're nice people
oh yeah they feed you and they give you
space it's all good for you when you're
broken those days i'ma Ralphie would
bring home a piece of salmon for me that
you a piece of salmon yeah I hate the
baked potatoes but isn't it cool now
were you talking about like these
markers and stuff what I love is uh you
know because like the podcast world and
because of how things have changed
online well and like we you specifically
like you know you have with you YouTube
and the podcasts such a big consistent
following that you don't need to worry
about any club because there's alt
venues in every city where you're
following is they don't care if your ex
you know [__] scoots McGee's laughs
you know chuckle Shack or you know Don's
Rock like whatever that they'll just go
to a venue that you want to go and it so
I just like comics have more freedom
than they've ever had that way where
it's like if you build that following
online and you get those fans that just
want to see you
you can work wherever those fans are and
it's amazing and I don't know if I know
of him but I don't know him Andrew
Schultz if you're a comedian and you're
not doing what Andrew Schultz is doing
today if you're in a stuck level and
yeah you're frustrated I want you to
follow Andrew Schultz and do everything
he does for bail I know he's been
killing it he just did a new special the
same day so far this one here on YouTube
oh you probably yeah you do yeah yeah
you just go for it
yep no good for him yeah I hope it's not
gonna work for you Andrew Schultz is
putting the time sure sure so before you
go maybe yeah yeah yeah put in 10 years
and ran he's got this out by doing it
right if you mimic Andrew Schultz you
will have success today yeah everything
to the tea the way he puts his material
up his social media his relationship
with the audience
nobody's doing that yeah he's doing a
[__] sensational job that's awesome I
mean yes that's the freedom yeah that we
have today is college to have that
direct relationship and we depend on
agents yeah for everything a booking
this yep that [__] Christ should put a
video of him up dancing I thought it was
all funny America's Got Talent
yep I post about that - yeah so yeah I
mean so you're at the store tonight yes
o'clock yes yes I you know I'm you know
I've actually never performed on that
stage before and you're the main rule I
know I'm wearing [__] around
I'm excited that I write it for you ah
yes sorry I have a PTA meeting Thursday
so I got look you're a good dad man huh
I love that you're a good dad for real
it's all I got left
well I'm planning you got late I'm so
many you know when you don't have a
father and then you have a lot of
fathers like I not that my mother was a
[__] I just had a lot of people who I
looked up to his father's yeah I I put
them up with the perfect father be
together ah
what would the ideal situation
in my head you know and I tried my
hardest she's a girl so they have a
couple more gaps to fill as a female you
have to fill those gaps for them but if
you're consistent with them you're gonna
get a heavy [__] head it I've seen
this formula done before you know I see
it's funny because we thought about
colleges I have a niece that just
started medical school that's awesome
she loves me I love her you know she's a
[__] gangster doesn't get high
doesn't drink one time I brought my
sister weed but I dropped it and she
found in his solder that's cool I mean
she's a gangster she's a gangster I love
it at that well so a way that she'll
live and die for me this nice I have
hard nieces that I'm tight with but she
doesn't like you know saying because
she's a college student right right
right
boy you're all you know we go out to
dinner she just shakes her head
sometimes she accepts me yes she loves
you she accepts me yeah it's so weird
with a sense of humor is Sharon on
Colleges early right but no I want it to
always be a good dad I've always wanted
to be yeah well you don't have a dad you
can't wait to be a dad
and I lost my first daughter not out of
being a good dad I lost because of not
having a good relationship with my wife
and what was going on with the drugs and
the calmly so when I got the second
chance
I rise to the occasion I rose to it
that's awesome man you have to yeah yeah
well you know what you don't have to no
but you did you chose to that's right
yeah that's like you know I said a lot
of people around in this town that their
fathers were successful but now these
kids are walking around lost mm-hmm
because at the end of the day they
didn't know their fathers what do always
on the road they have memories and their
fathers but I guarantee you know right
it's not the memories that and it's the
little things you know for years I
thought you had to buy your kids all
this stuff and spend all this money in
Disney high you know my daughter if I
just sit there and watch duck tales in
her and let her explain it to me yeah
I'll let her explain the characters it
means more to her than anything in the
world and a trip around the [__]
world yeah
amazing what you
you know so I think that it's a good
balance for comedy mm-hmm really been a
great balance for me yeah this age
because kids don't they don't care if
you killed or if you ate it whatever
they just want dad to love them and want
to spend time with that it's beautiful
that's it yeah that's it so I try to put
as much time as I can and you know yeah
I started the podcast with the science
but I love that she won't shut the [__]
up like all her 8ball she won't shut the
[__] she won't shut up she's like all
night Roseanne yeah yeah just pop up
something out of the blue and just run
with it yeah sure whoa that's awesome
man but I'm happy you shoot this special
thanks man same with you uh location
where you shoot Pontiac crow foot
ballroom and people put links up to know
before the oh yeah he's on sale one of
them's yeah they don't have yeah we had
a couple tickets left it's much smaller
yeah but uh yeah that and then uh scared
to death that that trailers out now that
just went out Lindsay and I are really
excited about that and time stuffs doing
well man uh it's so different now isn't
that crazy I think about I'm excited
about the special don't get me wrong I
love stand up I'm said that special but
I've gotten so into like podcast stuff
and like I let that stuff even I don't
love it more but I just love that you
can create your own project to
continually kind of promote talk about
and have that no one can take from you
you know you can just put stuff out that
you that you're passionate about and
people can find it right away it's it's
the best management oh you [__] let
it there's no excuses right there isn't
no one's stopping you know it's juice
you you don't to pay to have a youtube
account kid I don't go to Montreal
doesn't matter
you know I talk about it's crazy now
we're all excuses no more yeah it's just
such a different one you know yeah you
don't make it it's your fault because
you have every tool twitch you could
take your dick on hitters people donate
right the [__] thing that you could
stab a woman and they'll donate you have
a thousand ways to become
you know what that changed our our lives
our thing is a mod is four times the
patreon we have had a crazy amount of
subscribers more than I ever expected
and they just it's the most beautiful
thing they're they're paying five bucks
a month because they just want to hear
it get they get an extra podcast a week
and this it's a different like this
little axillary podcast it goes with
it's like little Clubhouse five they
just want that and they want to support
the regular show and that was something
that five years ago I wouldn't have been
ready I would have felt weird about it
for whatever he's just my own stupid
[__]
I'd like well I know he's supposed to do
a show and then you know there's a
different route and then I realized
there's no rules I kept thinking about
that I I didn't hear him say this to me
but Rory Scovel really funny comic
somebody told me they're asking him
advice and he was like who told you
there were rules and I needed to hear
that I was like no rule there's no
[__] rules and it's just in this
thing now where they have changed our
life like you know like less than six
thousand fans over you know total to do
that have changed our whole life they
allowed us to hire a couple people they
allowed us to have a studio they allowed
us to buy equipment to take chances on
other shows and now that's where all of
my energy is and it's just in what's
weird now is now people are wanting to
do auditions and things that I don't
even want to do because I'm like no I'm
[__] it I got this I got my thing
this is what I want yeah this is it no
it's beautiful spinner it's it's been
great for community it's a wonderful
time to be an artist yes yes let's just
say yeah a wonderful time to be an
artist and if you're thinking about it
say it you have no [__] excuse your
phone has everything now you can edit
videos you can shoot videos in 4k you
can do all that stuff it electrify
yourself with that [__] thing [__]
you won't do that closing bit where you
smash your [__] dick phones
everything's right there any date you
can show it up your ass you can light us
on fire
yeah the happy murder to day that we
call it but the dates
yes throughout the rest of year I can't
remember what's your website Dan Cummins
dot TV okay they're all on that old Dave
Chapelle [__] oh I can't pull that out I
can't pull that off I can take
everything down people have season isn't
it
oh yeah I know we got to stop it's the
Dave Chappelle I don't know this might
be a myth but since just talking about
mystique of Dave Chappelle I heard this
story I I don't know why they would live
wasn't true but they said that Dave
Chappelle was in Portland Oregon and he
went down to a park with like a little
portable speaker and a mic this is a
couple years after the Chappelle show in
a way and just started in some kind of
maybe there was like a speaker's day
where people kind like a Hyde Park
situation but anyway just started doing
just talk telling stories and within
like an hour there was over a thousand
people that had just gathered around to
[__] witness and then it just [__]
like a weird Pied Piper but I used to
hear stories I was aware destroy her
thought I wasn't there don't know if
it's true but I just I love the mystique
I love what he shows talk about comics
holding hands earlier it's just so cool
to see what one person can accomplish
through comedy and what he's doing right
now it's just it's like magical and you
cheer for him
yes it's not like other comics that have
had success and you know this scumbags
know this this guy that pulling the wool
over people's eyes no he's a real deal
Kevin Hart's the real deal oh that's
great you know there's a lot Russell
Peters yes yes yeah yeah no we're living
in a society you know I guess because of
the time but they have nothing to be
angry right right you know yeah I wish
them all the luck in the world yeah me
me too maybe too it made me so happy to
watch especially I might cheer and laugh
awesome awesome you know you were coming
thank you very much thank you thank good
store yes eight o'clock they're coming
Dick's machinist [__] light no fire
don't forget the 13th of September I am
in Dallas as a few tickets left San
Antonio sold out on the 14th and I got
the Chicago Teeter on the 27th
tremendous [__] show that's it and
that's that old [__] hold on I got do a
little word from our sponsors first off
number one listen fall is here all right
it's over the summer is done after this
weekend and it's time to be a [__]
gentleman the holidays are coming and
everybody wants to have a wife or a
girlfriend nobody wants to be alone
so it's time you clean your bumper
before you get your tailpipe sucked all
right
my friends over at manscape created the
only tool you need to shave your balls
and the area around the love stick it's
called a lawn mower 2.0 for a reason
they threw away the 1.0 they upgraded
their trimmer with the skin-safe
technology no more stresses you have
your wife trim your ball hairs and you
gotta [__] pray to God he don't miss
and she's not in the bad mood those days
are over with her right and for you mow
mows in the back that means you won't
Nick or snag your nutsack
plus it's perfect for travel just in
case you like doing that [__] when
there's nobody around picking your leg
up behind your neck and shaving that
area between your nutsack and you
[__]
call the stink festival manscape does it
all you understand me
and you could do it one-handed even if
you have a little hoof with a [__]
hook you can still use man's cape and
get your [__] schlong looking shiny
this is the first time you've considered
manscaping they got a deal for you all
right it's called the perfect package it
comes with a lawn mower and a safety
razor plus the crop preserver especially
formulated deodorant so your balls don't
stink and the Reviver it comes in a
little package let's just pretend you
bump into a [__] you take it out you
take it out of the package you wipe your
nut second the helmet you clean all the
goo around the [__] bottom of the
base and she sucks your dick and it's
like a mint [__] life saving their
mouth who was does that feel
but manscape that's what the perfect and
with the perfect package you get a pouch
all right and yeah and your pole will be
perfect what the [__] are you waiting
for this is the deal of a lifetime the
church family gets 20% off your first
order when you use promo code church at
manscape Tom and if you order the
perfect package they also throw in the
free travel bag when you use code Church
CH you are CH that's manscape com use
promo code church for 20% off your first
order and keep your balls clean the
church is also brought to you by hems 4
hems com
listen to me we got problems
we're losing our hair our erections
aren't working like they used to you
know we're getting older what you need
to do is help and it's here for you with
uncle Joey with age comes wisdom but
when you get older that could also be it
down in one specific area 40% of men by
the age of 40 struggle from not being
able to maintain an erection why the
[__] would you go to a liquor store and
buy like big dick pills and injections
when no man wants an injection listen
right now we can help you out you don't
have to go to a doctor and share your
experiences with them and be embarrassed
be wise checkout hims go-to for hims
calm a one-stop solution for hair loss
skin care and sexual wellness hims
connects you with real licensed doctors
and fda-approved
pharmaceutical products to treat edy
well known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help combat
your little problems description
solutions backed by science and made
more affordable see the results were
other treatments fall short no painful
injections no doctor visits nothing
answer a couple questions about your
Mester your medical history chat with a
doctor and it's over if you're approved
by the doctor the products they ship
directly to your door it's a reptile
dysfunction without being a dysfunction
it's hard made easy say hello to my
little friend
so try hims for a month for just $5 you
like Joey what the [__] you talking
about five hours will get you started
for five bucks while supplies last
description products are subject to
doctor's approval and require an online
consultation with a physician who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate see the website for full
details this could cost you hundreds if
you went to a doctor in person uncle
Joey's here to save the day alright go
to for hims calm slash Church CH you are
CH that's for hims calm slash Church
want that for him I want to thank
manscape
I want to thank [__] on it I want to
thank sip recruiter and I want to thank
my bookie AG for being great sponsors
this wee
but most importantly I want to take you
guys to find on the podcast supporting
us and always being [__] family to us
so without further ado have a happy
weekend don't forget to follow Dan
Cummings we're at Dan Cummins comedy or
time sucker yeah oh the website Dan
Cummins dot TV Dan Cummins dot TV have a
great weekend be safe don't get bit by a
shark and get your dick sucked I'll
leave you with debt Lee kick this [__]
meal